we need to talk about recycling I hear a
lot of people tell me I recycle well I'm
here to tell you I want you to stop
recycling no thanks okay okay well
actually I'd like you to focus less on
recycling and more on reducing we have a
huge plastic problem it's in everything
from our clothes to the fish we eat only
9% of all the plastic that gets produced
actually gets recycled we've been asked
producing plastic since the 1950s
classic can take up to 450 years to
break down and 60% of all that plastic
is still on our planet
plastic production creates greenhouse
gases which contribute to climate change
what you need to understand about
recycling is that it's only as valuable
as a market for it recycling is a
billion-dollar industry just because you
put something in the recycling bin
doesn't mean that it actually gets
recycled it has to be processed bailed
put on the market and if someone doesn't
buy it it doesn't get recycled
in fact 50% of the things and recycling
bins aren't recycled up until January of
2018 China was importing and processing
nearly half of the world's plastic and
paper recyclables
but they aren't accepting nearly as much
plastic waste as they used to which has
left the recycling industry in a crisis
around the world recyclable materials
have been going to landfill and
polluting environments we have all this
plastic and we keep producing more to
meet demand
but our earth is swimming in plastic so
that's why I'm asking you to focus on
reducing your use of plastics rather
than just recycling
[Music]
it